une rentrée sociale sous tension pour le
gouvernement le premier ministre qui
reçoit les partenaires sociaux
aujourd'hui et demain c'est l'occasion
d'aborder comme l'a dit jean marc
sylvestre les dossiers sensibles comme
la réforme des retraites et celle de
l'allocation chômage qui doit entrer en
vigueur théoriquement le 1er octobre
prochain les syndicats cgt fsu et force
ouvrière ont déjà appelé à une grande
mobilisation et à une grève générale le
5 octobre et pour en parler justement on
va retrouver notre reporter katia
technique qui suit les choses de très
près devant matignon
[Musique]
bonjour katia quelles vont être les
sujets abordés aujourd'hui entre jean
castex et les partenaires sociaux
mais bonjour en effet de réforme
reportée par la crise sanitaire
cristallise les tensions et ce n'est pas
pour rien que la manifestation dont vous
parlez est prévu en effet les syndicats
s'attendent à croiser le fer avec le
gouvernement
même si les réunion d'aujourd'hui qui
s'échelonne jusqu'à vendredi vont être
bilatéral c'est à dire qu'on s'attend
plutôt à des concertations des avis le
gouvernement ne fera pas d'annoncé il
dans une posture d'écouté ainsi jean
castex et le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire la ministre du travail le
secrétaire d'état aux retraites laurent
pietra c'est le ski recevront différents
syndicats notamment cet après midi le
chef de la cfdt laurent berger leur a
également y verriez de force ouvrière
jeudi philippe martinez et de la cgt
geoffroy roux de bézieux le chef du
medef et ensuite on finira avec benoît
test secrétaire générale de la fsu alors
commençons par les sujets les moins
polémique comme le revenu d'engagement
pour les jeunes pour soutenir les jeunes
qui ne sont pas employés ou qui ne sont
pas actuellement en formation avec un
montant fixé à 500 euros pour aider ces
travailleurs précaires autre sujet la
formation professionnelle qui n'est pas
au beau fixe il ya également les
difficultés de recrutement le pass
sanitaires et ses conséquences sur le
monde du travail et puis la contribution
des partenaires sociaux au futur plan
d'investissement et puis bien entendu
les fameuses de réforme controversés à
commencer par celle de l'assurance
chômage qui entrera en vigueur le 1er
octobre elle entraînerait une baisse
d'indemnisation pour 1,15 million de
travailleurs de 17% en moyenne et de 40%
pour les plus précaires on parle ici des
métiers de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration par exemple les syndicats
se sont déjà fortement mobilisés à ce
sujet et puis autre sujet qui hérisse et
bien la mise en place de la réforme des
retraites avec
système universel souhaitée par le
gouvernement la fin des 42 régimes
spéciaux et puis surprise car il y avait
une promesse de ne pas y toucher et bien
le report de l'âge de la départ pardon
en retraite qui était jusqu'ici fixé à
62 ans et les syndicats l'ont bien
répéter les hors de question d'aborder
ce sujet avant la fin du quinquennat
alors les commentateurs se perdent en
conjectures skis emmanuel macron va
aborder à abandonner cette réforme en
tout cas avant la fin de son mandat
toutefois quand même ses ministres on
parle toujours ainsi sur son importance
comme bruno le maire oui lisabeth bornes
merci beaucoup katia technique pour
toutes ces précisions